[Music]
[Applause]
he's the better looking of the McCourty
Brothers he's Devin McCourty the
Patriots safety won three Super Bowls
and uh he joins us on the program I
thought that'd bring a smile to your
face I called you the better looking
mccordy brother
it's been rough man everywhere I've gone
so far all I keep hearing about is how
great he's doing on TV he's this he's
that I just don't see it why is he not
playing or why are you still playing
uh well he he started a year before me
so I had to make sure I caught up to him
um but you know he he got uh old and
slow so yeah
all right we're gonna play
game and uh Paulie would you give the
official rules here Devin can't play but
he can listen to this so Devin started
his career as a cornerback then switched
to Safety in year three okay so he has
played 205 career games at cornerback
basically out of how many games 205 he
started every game of his career so I
got me thinking that seems like a lot of
games for a safety wow over 200. okay
how many safeties in NFL history have
started 205 games or more like Devin
McCourty has
and can you name any of them can we name
it
did one play for
the Steelers
no I'll give you the teams there's only
three all time one was a patriot for
quite a while one was an eagle forever
one was mostly in Atlanta
lawyer Malloy oh 213 starts Brian
Dawkins 221 starts and Eugene Robbins
that's the only three in history that
better than damn that's pretty good
company there
yeah that's that's not bad at all now
you you don't have load management if
you're an NBA player you wouldn't be
playing every single game I mean you
you've started every game you've played
it yeah
we don't have that in football you know
we're always told availability uh is the
best thing you can bring to the team
you faced uh Joe burrow what do you see
with Joe if you're if you're on Kansas
City or you were talking to somebody on
the uh the Chiefs what would you say do
this don't do that against Joe Bro
I think one of the biggest things that
Kansas have to do is you got to disguise
coverage um when we played them watching
film you could tell he was reading
coverages pretty well but when we got
out there different disguises things we
were doing in the beginning part of the
game it really felt like he had a beat
on us I mean I think I think he might
have had three incompletions in the
first half something something
ridiculous and just kind of marching up
and down the field and we did a better
job in the second half
um not only disguising but also running
multiple coverages different things
running coverages that look like other
coverages
um so you definitely you don't want to
line up uh really in the same defense
over and over again or just stand still
um because he's that good and there's
receivers that he's thrown to they're
pretty good too so you're gonna have a
long day if you don't do a good job
disguising coverages and just competing
against those guys what would you do
with Mahomes how would your strategy be
different knowing that he has this high
ankle spring
that's the hard thing man um
you know watching yesterday I just saw a
couple of things on Twitter with him
jogging around the field
um by Sunday I don't I just don't know
about this weekend that ankle might be
pretty good I don't know if you're going
to be able to do a lot different a lot
differently than what you have would
have normally done he might not be as
mobile but I still think he's going to
be able to move around the pocket
um pretty well just because if he's
moving out well on a Wednesday
um you just kind of look forward and you
fast forward to by the end of the
weekend he's going to be feeling
probably pretty good and you know the
continued treatment and what he'll do on
game day for that ankle I think he'll be
moving pretty well explain to me why
Travis Kelsey is always open
well I will say watching the the Jaguar
game once my homes got hurt I would have
changed my whole game plan up and we
would have doubled Kelsey every play I
don't care I don't care if we would have
had a gaping hole in the coverage
somewhere else uh we would have doubled
them but I think he's such a mismatch
you know you try to put a corner on them
or a smaller safety that can run with
him he does a good job using his length
his strength um and if you put a
linebacker on him he's just too athletic
and then I think the biggest thing he
does is like you said if you play zone
he understands how to get in the gaps
how to get open don't run the coverage
uh my homes knows them so I think you
put those two guys together you have a
guy that is a big Target and he got a
quarterback that understands where he's
going to be you're in for a long day and
he continues to do that in the playoffs
uh throughout the regular season but
what if what's the difference between
trying to cover Kelsey and trying to
cover Gronk in practice
uh Grog just was I mean he's humongous
you know I think you know I think Kelsey
naturally was is a better route Runner
uh the different things he was able to
do when he first got in the league for
me I came in with Gronk as a rookie so
um the evolution of grunk of being able
to but I think brilliant his prime when
he was really killing he was a good
route Runner he understood how to run
right up on defender's toes but I just
think Gronk is just so big uh it was
always tough to even get past breakups
to reach around him and get to the ball
and then Tom used to put the ball only
where you couldn't get it it was almost
an impossible cover he's Devin McCourty
the Patriots safety won three Super
Bowls your favorite Brady story
is what
um favorite Brady story
I'll probably I'll probably say
Obviously a lot of stories
um playing with them and winning games
but it was fun competing against them
back you know last year when we played
Tampa I think you know early in October
um later in the game uh you know when
you play Brady you got to be you got to
be on it and you got to be smart your
strategy has to be you know on point so
at some point later in the game we
finally decided to go on all out Blitz
uh and he got us a little bit with the
snap count so as he's sitting there he
smiles at us
um knowing knowing what's coming and he
can please surpass to break and I'm I'm
running down on them and as soon as he
came police to pass moving backwards he
goes come on dad Blitz zero you think
I'm not gonna know that and starts
laughing uh and it just reminded me of
all the battles we had in practice of
talking trash and us always telling him
he was lucky we couldn't hit him uh and
then him doing it in the game it's just
a true Brady moment Rodney Harrison
would talk about how Brady would do get
so upset with the defense in practice
yeah oh we've had we've had times where
he's taken the ball punted it in the
stands and we're in the stadium throwing
the ball instead of throwing the ball
away like out of bounds he Chucks the
ball 20 yards over the fence so somebody
has to go get the ball
um those are the days as a defense where
because once that happens now we're not
stopping we're we're going to keep
talking to him keep getting them angry
um but I will say those are the days
that made our team better uh throughout
training camp in the season everybody
who plays for the Patriots they all say
Bill Belichick is funny he just never
shares that with us so go ahead Devin
tell me that Bill Belichick is funny
okay I'll tell you this I've had to do a
lot of production meetings
um the night before the game you know my
13-year career I hate going after him
because you watch his press conferences
it's you know quick answers every once
in a while I give a long answer but you
get him in those production meetings
with his guys that you've seen over the
years like this our last game against
Buffalo I have to go after him and
Romo's in there and Nance and I'm in
there and now I'm waiting to go they're
still going 15 minutes go by finally
they're like you know these guys got to
get off to meeting so I finally sit down
but now Romo gets up with Bill walks
over to the door and they're still
talking Romo they're over there laughing
and joking
um so it is cool to see him you know
behind the scenes and I think not only
the players different people I would say
in the football world that he's known
for a while uh and has good
relationships with they also see that
other side of him
um that's pretty unique that you don't
always see from a media standpoint
well good luck congratulations you're
playing next year right
I'll still I'll still figuring that out
for a second I thought you were telling
me that they were going to put us in the
AFC Championship game this weekend
because if somebody got disqualified so
I was really I was I was liking that
good luck too but now I'm figuring out
and gonna take some time
um over these next few months vacation
with the family just enjoy some down
time uh and then see how I feel in a
couple months you can make the
announcement right here
here it is this end Devin McCourty
former Patriot safety
how would my brother feel if I did that
he would probably want me to to do
something oh you're right he'd be pretty
angry you're right you're right trying
to get me in trouble man will you make
the announcement of what you're doing
next year with your brother
I'm gonna ask my kids my daughter she's
five now she's been adamant uh on me not
playing football anymore so uh whatever
I decide I'll let her decide how we do
it okay I think that would be nice give
your brother you know something you know
help his career a little bit help yeah
well he makes fun of me so much on TV
I'm not sure every every time I have a
bad play he puts me up on a segment but
anytime I have a good play I've never
seen any of my good plays on his show so
well help a brother out literally help
her brother uh Devin thank you thanks
for joining us we appreciate it and I
appreciate you thanks for having me
Devin McCourty we uh won three Super
Bowls there Patriots safety his brother
is uh Jason mccording he's done some
nice work in the media there